thank you Ernie and first of all let me
thank Salt Lake City and Utah for being
tremendous hosts Governor Cox mayor
Mendenhall thank you very much to Gail
Miller for bringing this All-Star to
Salt Lake City to Ryan and Ashley Smith
for being fantastic hosts we really
appreciate it and now for the MVP I
don't think there's much suspense an
all-time record most points scored ever
the Kobe Bryant All-Star MVP trophy to
the I'm sorry the the Kobe Bryant trophy
for the Kia MVP Jason Tatum
foreign
[Applause]
double nickels in an All-Star Game
all-time record-breaking Anthony Davis's
mark and it all really took shape in the
third quarter when you scored a record
27.
yeah we just came out see your first
three going and keep shooting uh stay
hot and just kept running and you had
that moment with your teammate
Chandler Brown when you guys were going
back and forth and that was the first
legit defensive
stop of the night as as you got him
doing not get a shot off at the end of
the third quarter yeah decided to be
competitive a little bit you know trying
to stay safe but uh just have some fun
with it and uh you know show JB he can't
score on me what does it mean to
you and here is an All-Star and they
will look at the record books and the
name at the top of that list of points
scored in an All-Star game is going to
be yours it means the world you know you
think of all the Legends and great
players that's played in this game and
in all honesty records are meant to be
broken so I'll hold it for as long as I
can but I'm certain somebody had come
along in a couple years and try to break
it Jason Tatum congratulations uh we've
already pointed out tonight that you're
the only Celtic to be an All-Star four
times uh at that age and you are uh your
credit to that organization and a credit
to all the All-Stars here tonight nice
going appreciate it
so
team Giannis over team LeBron here in
the 72nd NBA All-Star Game reminder you
can